ceos and corporate insiders have sold a
record amount of stock this year in
2021. we still have one month to go but
yet they are selling tons and tons of
stock there's been 69 billion
of stocks sold from ceos and corporate
insiders during the first 11 months of
the year this is up more than 30 percent
from last year in 2020 and it is 79
higher than the 10 year average robert
frank over at cnbc did a fantastic
breakdown of these stock sales so first
we have the insider sales what you can
see is that we continue to see higher
and higher sales by insiders and
corporate ceos on top of that we then
you can see that the largest stock
sellers are actually people that you
would probably expect elon musk jeff
bezos walton family mark zuckerberg
larry page and sarah gay brynn now what
is fascinating to me is if you add up
the top four sellers elon musk jeff
bezos walton family and mark zuckerberg
they make up about 37 percent of that 69
billion dollars of insider sales now
also important to note is that all of
these stock sales for the most part go
through a
process where they have to pre-declare
well in advance that they are going to
sell the stock it is not like one day
they just wake up and they say oh you
know what i'm gonna sell two billion
dollars worth of my stock today it's not
what happened obviously that would bring
incredible scrutiny confusion and
potential problems legally from
shareholders and so there's an entire
process that they follow in order to
pre-clear and predetermine when they're
going to sell the stock but still seeing
10 billion stock sales six billion four
and a half and a billion and a half
dollars coming from the google founders
is obviously brings to question is this
a top signal are we seeing people raise
their hand and say we think that this is
a frothy market well you have to ask
yourself why are they selling the stock
part of the stock sales are coming
because they do believe that the stock
price is appreciated significantly and
they should take some risk off and go
ahead and liquidate some of the stock
some of the stock sales are coming if
you look at something like
jeff bezos he says he sells the stock to
fund things like blue origin other stock
sales are happening because there are
tax ramifications there are at the
federal level conversations happening
where the capital gains tax may increase
five to eight percent depending on how
much money you make on top of that there
are places like the state of washington
that is implementing starting in 2022 an
additional seven percent capital gains
tax in that state so if you work at
microsoft you work at amazon et cetera
then maybe if your residence is in
washington you would be selling stock
today to avoid those stock sales again
if you sold 10 billion worth of stock
jeff bezos and they implement that seven
percent there's about 700 million
dollars in tax savings if by selling it
this year rather than next year so i
personally don't actually think this is
as concerning as many people would say
if you think about it most of these
people as they've sold stock along the
way of building their companies those
stocks have continued to appreciate many
of these stocks are trading at all time
highs so not necessarily just having ceo
sales or insider sales is a market top
signal but what i do think is very
interesting is that this is abnormal
it's over 80 percent it's about 80
percent higher than the 10-year average
for ceo and insider sales the question
is next year will be even higher or is
this the top how did you guys read when
you saw that 69 billion dollars of ceo
and insider stock was sold in the first
11 months this year is that concerning
or is it like uh market prices have gone
up a lot there's high inflation of
course they're going to be selling stock
into the market i think it depends like
you obviously need some level of context
for this stuff because there's a bunch
of reasons i mean there's a million
different reasons why they might be
selling right whether it's personal tax
bills uh elon musk tweeted and was
joking about hey if you guys all let
twitter decide but it came out later on
that uh he had a bunch of options that
he had previously said were expiring at
the end of this year anyway so he had to
sell some stock he had a big tax bill
coming we know that the tax law is
changing in washington so a bunch of
executives and microsoft people that
live there are selling tax to meet some
of those tax bills before they get hit
uh so they're like there's just a
million different reasons i guess is my
main point so you need context to figure
out kind of what's happening i don't
think it necessarily means that they're
expecting some massive drop off in in
price uh there's a bunch of speculation
out there but i think as with everything
else you kind of just need some context
around uh everyone's individual
situation because as we know must sold
for one reason uh you know jeff bezos
might be selling for another and so on
so i think it's uh it's difficult to
look at in a vacuum and just say hey
look everyone thinks the stock market's
going to decline that's why they're
selling got it john will do so for
different reasons but man i
the general person elon musk fooled you
thinking that the twitter poll
determined if he was selling stock or
not he already knew he was selling the
stock 10 billion dollars worth of tesla
he
he just pulled a fast one over on the uh
the average audience and then when it
came out i have a feeling a lot of
people didn't even know that that uh
came out still so that's why we're kind
of talking about it but 69 billion
dollars a lot of money it's a lot of
money to be selling um especially with
all-time highs and if inflation persists
we should see asset prices if the fed
keeps printing asset prices should
continue to go up so taxes are coming
the rich are getting ready follow what
they're doing
i can't say that enough